all right guys
bang bang super excited to have joe here
uh thanks so much for doing this man
thanks so much for having me on the show
pump i'm actually really excited i've
uh obviously been a fan and watching
your show for a long time
and uh really honored to be
part of the ranks absolutely so for
those that are just listening and not
getting the pleasure of watching joe
he is currently in a room where
literally he's got a white board behind
him and he just wrote bison trail so
joe gets the award for the best
marketing to ever be on the show
uh but before we talk about bison trails
let's start with
uh kind of you've been an entrepreneur
investor for quite a long time
um and had a number of exits and kind of
worked at
etsy and other places so just walk us
through kind of your background and kind
of everything you did pre-crypto
definitely definitely um and i like uh
it's funny i kind of
uh whether i like it or not i sort of
think of my
career as pre and post crypto um
which which which is great because i can
kind of talk a little bit about
pre-crypto post-crypto but then there's
also that
that sort of messy middle um where i was
already into crypto but not full time
into crypto and that's actually one of
my favorite
zones to talk about because it actually
talks about that transition
um but you know to get to get back to
your question um that's right of uh
so i'm joe lolus i'm the ceo and
co-founder of bison trails
uh and uh we're an infrastructure
company in the blockchain space
um and i've been a startup founder for a
long time my co-founder and i have been
working together this is so this is the
crazy part this is this is really
where things are kind of nuts my
co-founder and i have been working
together for the better part of
17 almost 18 years which is
i'm pretty insane as far as co-founders
go in fact
if you've ever followed any kind of
startup or you know early stage company
mantras or stories you it's not uncommon
to hear that the biggest reason why
um companies fail is because partners
that start a company
don't work out in terms of relationships
and friendships and stuff so
i'm super proud of that and him and i've
been working together for a really long
time
we're both technical so we both have a
technical background software
engineering backgrounds
um have spent a lot of time building the
first versions of everything we've done
and
this kind of becomes you know a little
bit more relevant in particular with
bicycles and what we're doing today
um but uh have spent a large part of my
career as an entrepreneur
uh in different stages of different
companies um we joke that we've
built uh three technically three
companies uh
venture back companies in the past um in
reality that probably looks more like 25
and 22 of them we never really talk
about
or or really have an opportunity to talk
about because they were you know massive
failures or never made it
further than a month out from an idea
board um
and uh and and so yeah you know um
spent spend some time uh building a few
different companies
and uh and spent some time doing some
angel investing
so that that's been that's been really
great um
a uh the last company that i worked on
was this company called grand street
we were an online marketplace uh
specifically for new consumer devices so
new hardware um one of the easiest ways
to think about that is think of the sort
of you know
kickstarter or indiegogo type of folks
people that wanted to
that you know they were quitting their
app their their job at apple or their
job at samsung they had this really
great idea for this new device
like a fitbit or a internet of things
scale or
something along those lines and uh
they uh wanted to go and build this new
product and so we built this marketplace
this company that manifested as a
marketplace just specifically for these
kinds of things so
bringing together buyers and sellers of
these these different products
what was really interesting about that
company behind the scenes was we were
actually building
a whole suite of technology tools to
make it easier for folks
to build design build
ship you know sell all of these new
types of products which is
which was a new product category and um
quite frankly pretty difficult to do so
um we coined this concept of apis for
manufacturing
which is really connecting uh this world
of software to this sort of world of
hardware
and using software to build sorry using
um sorry this world of software in this
world of manufacturing and using um
software to be able to bring
the the two sides together i'm creating
efficiencies there and
if you know anything about the
production world or the manufacturing
world you know there's a
huge amount of barriers to entry um
a lot of walls to sort of climb over and
it's really really hard to break into it
so
it was a cool company we spent a lot of
time in shenzhen and china
working with different contact
manufacturers and different folks that
were building electronics over there
and then a lot of time in the united
states working with folks that were
doing things like plastics injection
moldings and
helping parallelize manufacturing runs
um the uh in 2014 we met the leadership
team
at etsy and etsy for those that don't
know is a publicly traded
marketplace for crafts and
we met we met the leadership team and
the leadership team was really
interested in this idea of using
software to help scale businesses and
democratize access
to these tools to make it easier for
independents
to participate in this idea in in this
like sort of global economy this idea of
this global economy
and so uh after some sort of back and
forth uh we
uh talked to to to the etsy uh
leadership team about
joining the team and joining the
leadership team there and uh and joining
joining the company and
building out um some of the businesses
uh that help support etsy sellers scale
i mean one of those businesses
was manufacturing um as well as a few
other uh businesses
uh business lines while we were there so
super super fun time
uh in 2014 i joined the leadership team
there
spent a few spent almost exactly three
years at etsy
uh which was a great time learned a ton
uh i like to sort of sort of talk about
there was um
you know two uh you know very very
unique experiences that
as a software company founder as a
startup founder
you don't really get to do uh one is you
know scale
and build a business uh that is a
multi-billion dollar business and
i'm not sure what that what etsy is
currently trading at today but you know
has grown tremendously over the last few
years which is fantastic and
the second thing is actually to take a
company public
um so while well obviously i wasn't on
the executive team at etsy while we were
doing that
being involved in the company as it
makes this transition from a private
company
to a public company as a startup founder
you don't really get to do
unless you do it yourself and get lucky
or you end up joining a company and do
it with them
and get lucky and so there's a lot of
timing luck involved there and
i feel incredibly fortunate to be able
to have done that um
so super super fun time yeah and as you
were
uh kind of at etsy you were there for
about three years so kind of seven
2017 give or take uh obviously the
crypto world's going crazy
kind of what was your um kind of balance
between like what i call the day job
which was continuing to kind of fulfill
the
role and responsibility that you had at
etsy which i'm assuming
you know either before or during 2017
you start saying like oh wait a second
there's this
crypto blockchain thing going on like
what was the first time you ever came
across it and kind of what drove some of
that interest
yeah so um my my entrance into the
crypto and blockchain space
is is came from two different angles
the first is alongside studying software
engineering and studying technology and
being a technologist
and a huge nerd i also actually studied
economics
and and both my co-founder and i were
dual majors in economics and technology
um and you know and um this this led for
a very perfect storm
of having very in-depth conversations
about
things like financial behavior financial
economics economics in general
and the intersection of technology and
software um
you know i think now it's a little bit
more lmod or popular to build like
sort of consumer fintech companies when
you know
earlier on in my career those that was
pretty on you know there's a lot less of
them there was a few you know you
obviously had
your paypal and and and that you know
and and that sort of cohort but
um you know you didn't have the
challenger banks that you have today
that are kind of coming out
and reassessing the entire sort of like
financial institution space so
um but uh but getting involved in crypto
was
one started with that deep interest from
a technology perspective and just being
a huge nerd and realizing there was
something going on here
and two is having that that economics
and sort of financial behavior
uh interest as well um my
uh first time digging into crypto was
bitcoin it wasn't anything else and it
actually wasn't in 2017. it was
i don't want to date it because i can't
i actually have like a bit of a pet
peeve when people are like i was in
crypto at like you know this moment the
truth is i'm actually not sure exactly
when it was
it was before we started building our
previous company because we were working
on another company
and this is a funny story one of the
engineers uh
at on the team who had left
we were sort of doing an audit of the
servers that we had for the company and
as we were doing an audit of these
servers we found these long-running
processes that were on these servers
and we're like what is going on here
this is realistic it was probably around
2011
i'd say like maybe 2010 2011. we're like
what is going on here this is so bizarre
like these servers are being used but
we're not using them like why is this
happening this guy had left turns out he
had been running bitcoin
miners on these company servers for god
knows how long maybe
six months 12 months who knows um
and uh and that was my first
introduction to bitcoin i was like this
is the coolest thing i've ever like you
know part of me is like that's terrible
we shouldn't have been doing that the
other part of me was like this is the
coolest thing i've ever seen
like you could wait hold on you can like
create this asset and you know and then
that's when i you know obviously the
naive me was like
how does this work what do you know
what's going on and i'm a huge nerd so
um that was my first time getting
involved with bitcoin in general
um actually when we were at grand street
the marketplace that we built
um we were still very interested i say
we because i speak a lot in wise because
aaron and i
uh my co-founder and i have spent a lot
of time doing a lot of this work
together
we were still very interested in bitcoin
and cryptocurrencies in general
um and we integrated with this company
that uh at the time was doing bitcoin
payments i think it was called diwala
i believe it was called the walla they
were one of the earlier sort of like
payment processor providers and we
integrated them as a payment provider
alongside stripe uh on on our
marketplace we did have to subsequently
unintegrate that product because it uh
there was a lot of fraud and it was kind
of like hard to
to do um to properly uh
um uh uh balance between crypto and the
volatility of crypto
and dollars and again like i should
reiterate this is in
you know 2012 or something this is a
long time ago and crypto's come a long
way since then
um so so i would say that crypto and
blockchains has kind of been weaved
through bits and pieces of my career
both from an interest perspective as
well as from an execution perspective
for the last
you know close to 10 years which is
super cool
um what did you do with the guy who uh
who was
running the scripts on the servers do
you guys uh go and kind of
slap his wrist and say hey you should
have done that or or did you go tell him
hey man you're pretty smart thanks for
introducing us to it
we didn't know we didn't know until he
was gone he had left the company already
i haven't talked to him since
he's probably sitting on a beach
somewhere
not not listening to this podcast
or even worse for you as he's listening
and being like damn they know
i mean look at that like his those are
his right those are his keys those are
his bitcoin
i mean it's unfortunate that that's
that's the route but
in all fairness i will say like there
were servers that the company wasn't
using so it was sort of like this excess
capacity concept this is back when you
could mine bitcoin on like a regular
computer you can't
you can't do that stuff anymore um so
that's a whole other world um but uh but
but getting back to your original
question in 2017
um i should say uh really
late 2016 early 2017.
2016 all of 2016 aaron and i were
spending a lot of time thinking about
sort of what we wanted to do next what
was sort of on the horizon
and we could not get away from this idea
that crypto and blockchains
and transfer value networks uh and
modern
crypto networks were going to be the
future and that there was
this was an inevitability uh that uh
this technology was going to be baked
into the products and services that we
use on a daily basis new products and
services that are going to be built and
designed
and um and if you think very like you
know i have a very technical mind
you know very software engineering
focused mind you think very sort of
technical about this
the idea of having computer systems that
can speak to each other and transfer
value automatically seamlessly and
trustlessly
is so obvious to me like today it's like
so obvious
and the systems are being built and
they're being tested and they're being
broken and they're being refixed and
they're being relaunched and new things
are being built like that's how
technology progresses but um that to me
was so obvious in in even in 2016 and so
the ico ico craze happened and
um i will say that like i did you know i
was around i definitely was doing some
investments
in the crypto space and i've never sold
a single
token that i've purchased i've never um
you know
that's not entirely true i did sell some
bitcoin at some point and i deeply
deeply regret it but
uh um you know i never i was never
really day trading any cryptos or
anything like that it was kind of like
mostly like looking at
interesting projects and investing in
them and saying like this could be this
could be something
that come uh you know it is part of the
future so
balancing the day job was hard it's
really hard as a founder
at a company at a big company and things
are there's a lot of moving parts it's
really really hard because you
constantly have that
itch of i got not like i got to go now
there's no i can't wait like six months
i can't wait a year like i have to do
this today you know
and um it's hard to truly explain that
idea
but uh it was really really hard and so
um you know if anybody from etsy is
listening to this now and i'm still
quite close with a few of them i feel
bad i probably wasn't
100 in on etsy in the last like six
months that i was there
because i was already sort of thinking
about like what i wanted to be working
on next
very common when uh when you acquire a
company and the startup founders are
there you know that they're not going to
be there for a decade
right and so it's just a matter of when
when do they start looking at other
things but
but i guess the question then is just
like what was the impetus for
what has now become bison trail so what
was that original idea where you guys
were like all right
you know we've kind of gone through all
these ideas in this space like here's
what we should go do and spend our time
and energy on
yeah um this is uh
honestly quite frankly like of all of
the projects and companies that i've
worked on
in in my career i actually think bison
trails has been the most
organic progression of an idea
and a concept of any of the other
projects we've worked on
um and and uh and i think it's super
cool it's actually a really fun story
for me to tell because
of how sort of progressive it is it's
kind of like it makes you think
you know you hear stories of companies
being built and you know
in hindsight you realize like oh yeah
like you know actually it was being used
this way
and that's where we started going then
all of a sudden it's like you have this
company that's scaling up and
we've sort of been experiencing that
over the last couple years which is
which is really quite cool
um so i kind of mentioned before that
you know aaron and i are both technical
we're both pretty big nerds
um so when we finally decided okay it's
time to jump
and actually build something uh build
something i should say not build
something in the crypto space but build
something
we took a year almost to sort of explore
and and
um you know this is advice that i
actually often give to you know early
stage founders which is
work on things you care about because
it's good inevitably at some point it's
going to be
shitty and make sure that you care about
it enough that when it's
not going well you don't give up and so
i think that you know we took that very
very seriously in this and that we
wanted to make sure we were
working on something we cared about and
and so really took a time to took the
time to explain i should say we're
already in crypto right we're already
like
i already had bitcoin i already had
ethereum i was already you know
investing in
other projects but it wasn't like okay
we've got to build a crypto company
um what ended up happening was it took a
year and basically read
every white paper that existed under the
sun
started to look beyond the the hype
cycles around crypto and look at some of
the deeper
research and applied technology that
that folks were working on
and realizing that there was this crazy
crazy depth of some of the most
intelligent
some of the weirdest and most
intelligent people you've ever met in
your entire life
that are trying to solve these very
serious problems in in you know
trustless systems
and decentralized systems and um
transfer value and store value networks
and you know
all the crypto and blockchain fun stuff
and uh that's when the the sort of you
know the rabbit hole
moment that's when like the the the
interest graph just took over
it was that there was no other thing
that i wanted to work on or cared about
working on it was like
even if i tried to explore another
industry it was like always like but how
does like crypto affect this
how's block how do blockchains affect
this um and so
that was um that's when the interest
graph kind of kicked in and
um and then and then it's like then
founder moment starts then it's like
okay now i'm interested in this and i
can't
whether i'm in the shower or whether i'm
you know i just woke up like whether i'm
on a run it doesn't matter what i'm
doing this is the only thing i'm
thinking about
and that's when that's when um you know
founder kicks in and it's like great
do how do i do not how do i learn more
about how do i do and
um and you know being that we're
technical team the only thing we really
know how to do is do really technical
things and kick into gear so
first question we asked ourselves was
how does everything work you know read
every white paper how does
how does this work and we had just spent
a large part of our careers
um exploring how do we democratize
access to systems and i kind of
mentioned this earlier like we were
building apis to manufacturing
how do you break down walls into this
and we're both very technical and we try
to
explore the blockchain space and realize
that this is hard this is not simple
technology it's not
easy it is not at the point where
if you're an entrepreneur and you want
to build a new product or service that
your mind immediately says like well i
should be using
krypton blockchains because that's where
this you know that's where
uh the the future is because it was
still very very difficult
and so that was kind of step one
step two was how do we understand the
infrastructure behind everything that's
going on
so we just very simply like ask
ourselves okay i understand bitcoin i
understand how it works but what's
powering bitcoin and why is it powering
bitcoin
uh and at the time the only thing that
was really powering this network the
majority
that was powering these networks was
mining and and and mostly proof of work
mining and
we have to get into the details of proof
of work mining but we did what every
startup founder does which is try to
figure out how mining works
um and uh and so we built like a small
mining test facility uh in in brooklyn
new york and
not not in in a sort of commercial sense
but just as an idea like to really
understand
how our blocks formed how our message is
propagated how does this system actually
work how is it trustless what happens if
you break it what happens if you know
what are the right ways to do this
realize that it was super interesting
and got a really strong grasp of the
infrastructure behind things like
bitcoin and other proof of work networks
and said great we get it in a in a
nutshell how does this work at scale
so we did the next thing startup founder
does is uh we
scaled it so um a little fun fact about
aaron and i that most people don't know
is we actually own a proof of work mine
we built from the ground up a proof of
work mine uh we spent
um we spent a few months uh
scouting different locations all around
the country
actually all around the world settling
eventually in the united states
uh and and really uh figuring out how to
optimize building a proof of work mine
optimizing how to build out the space
and how to where to position it how to
negotiate power contracts and
i'm sure you know your your audience
probably knows enough about mining that
we didn't
we don't need to talk about mining but
there's a whole lot of things that go
into that and
part of the name is actually from is is
a hat tip to the time that we spent in
in in in spots like wyoming and
uh montana in the pacific northwest uh
trying to build out this first version
of like infrastructure in the space and
so we ultimately did that and so we
built up like what would be considered
pretty big for two people uh but small
on you know bitmain scale or whatever
um proof of work mine and wrote a bunch
of software to optimize it and automate
a bunch of them we still own it we still
want to approve workline
which is it's a whole other independent
fund can of worms
um and so uh you know in this
progression of
in this learning progression as a
founder it kind of started as like a
deep interest in understanding the white
papers and the technology and then you
get into the supplied interest of
understanding the infrastructure and how
it works and what's powering it
and that's when you start to unlock the
the sort of
the openness of how you can innovate and
build once you know what's there and you
understand how the pieces are their work
then you start to envision a future
where those things are easier and and
you can
build the pieces to make it easier so
aaron and i started working on a few
different projects
not companies but projects in the space
we built a bot that was
trading on exchanges for fun we had
built uh you know we started building
this like
a wallet app and we built a few other
products and services and every single
time we built
one of these different products or
pieces of software
we realized we kept rebuilding this
robust piece of infrastructure
to participate in the blockchain itself
so you're building
uh connectivity into these networks that
are by
definition and by design you know
decentralized unreliable because it
creates that creates the security and
resiliency um so we had spent a lot of
time rebuilding these
these pieces and ultimately you know at
one point there was an aha moment
where we turned to each other and we're
like okay so we built like three
different things but every time we build
one of these things we're rebuilding
this like you know
underlying infrastructure layer and
we're like scratching our heads and
we're like okay well so we understand
infrastructure really well
at scale in the space we keep rebuilding
this thing maybe we should ask other
people
if they're having the same problem you
know like it feels like silly but
at the same time that's really how it
went you know and so we um
so started asking a few other founders
that i that i had met in the crypto
space like hey what is your engineering
team look like what are some of your
challenges
and almost every single person we talked
to was like well like 20
of our resources are focused on like
connecting to bitcoin or ethereum or
you know running nodes that are helping
us read and write to the network
or you know trying to fix
unreliable services that that you know
apis that we're trying to use to read
from ethereum or right to bitcoin
uh and uh and you know that at that
moment erin and i are like
okay so this is a problem we have we're
solving our own problem we've
talked to a few folks in the space and
clearly they have the problem
and this is very very very clearly
something that will make it easier
for folks to come into the space and
build new products and services so
aligns incredibly well with our
interests with our backgrounds with our
ability to
solve infrastructure problems but also
democratize access to blockchains and so
like i wish that i had like a you know a
moment where like i
you know i turned on a light switch and
all of a sudden i was like i should
build an infrastructure company in the
blockchain space but that's not at all
what happened it was really like a
series of events that kind of turn
around we realized oh there's
something here and then the next phase
is building
that company you know this company is
going to get built whether we build it
or not so
let's start building the infrastructure
platform to make it easier for people to
do this and
started building the first version of it
and talking to early customers and kind
of getting them on board a few years ago
and
from there that's that's really the the
story and so when you talk about
infrastructure and kind of your product
offering maybe just
you know dig a little deeper on just
like what do you mean by infrastructure
because i think when people hear that
they think like
pick shovels you know oil and gas and
kind of bridges and toll booths and you
know like
like that type of world so what does
that mean in the kind of
bitcoin and crypto world and then in
terms of how
customers interface with you what
exactly are the products that you're
offering them today
yeah and um i love that i love that um
the imagery that you're sort of putting
out there right picks
shovels toll booths highways that those
are the things that we are building for
the blockchain space we're building
infrastructure for the blockchain space
for blockchains what that means is
generally speaking computing computing
power storage power
that provides access for people to read
for companies or individuals to read and
write or help secure or produce blocks
so blockchains are really you know a
protocol is really just a set of
instructions and computers implement
those instructions
and people companies people individuals
need to run those computers to implement
those instructions and we've built a
platform
that makes it so you don't need to be
technical at all to run computers that
implement those instructions so
with two clicks you can run a a node
that is
helping secure the cosmos network uh
you can you know with two clicks you can
run a a series of node clusters that are
distributed all around the world that
are using a whole variety of different
cloud providers
for resiliency and for resistance and
for fall tolerance
and run auto scale polka dot
infrastructure for instance
um similarly if you wanted to uh if you
had a business or you were an exchange
or a custodian or an asset manager
or a data company and you wanted to very
regularly
connect to the bitcoin network read from
it right to it for
on behalf of your customers you actually
need to support
build and deploy and manage node
infrastructure to be able to do that
which is a non-trivial task to do at
scale
securely and reliably and so uh our
customers will use our platform to do
that instead
and so the products we offer right now
we're focused on
we're really focused on newer proof of
stake networks so
uh networks that uh are using proof of
stake is a consensus mechanism instead
of proof of work
um and the reason for that is because
proof of stake as opposed to using
mining and asic mining and sort of
these very specific computers to secure
the network proven stake uses
uh basically general
generalized computers and they use stake
as a mechanism or or
asset value as a mechanism to secure the
network so you're
incentivized uh to behave appropriately
and disincentivize financially to
behave you know poorly and so you can do
that
running somewhat of a regular computer
in like a cloud environment
however it needs to be incredibly
incredibly secure because these are
you know effectively giant honey pots so
we have this very very very
huge uh secure infrastructure platform
and we run nodes on all of these
different networks
bitcoin ethereum cosmos tezos
algorithm you know you name it polka dot
just launched pretty recently
and there's a whole bunch of new
networks that are coming out as well um
so
so that's basically um what our platform
does and
and again just to reiterate what we say
when we what we mean when we say
infrastructure is we literally mean
computers and these computers are
essentially tuned to do different things
like
read and write from a chain um you know
i like the tollbooth
kind of uh analogy uh so you know also
like potentially process transactions
and take fees right so if you imagine
like a message getting propagated
through a blockchain
uh then there's nodes that are
propagating that and you know they will
take
uh transaction fees to propagate those
messages
um not all that dissimilar from like
let's say a tollbooth on a
toll road and so we uh we run
all these computers on our platform and
we build a platform to do this
and for customers basically what they're
doing is the
the interface with you is through apis
and then you guys have
all this infrastructure built out and so
uh i'm envisioning
um basically uh i'm building a company
let's say it's a consumer-facing
business i want to support a bunch of
different assets rather than me go and
have to
build out the actual infrastructure
support every single one of those assets
i can essentially come to your business
and say hey here's the four of the
you know 12 15 assets that you guys
support today i want to interface with
these four
i hit some api and basically get kind of
a robust
set of uh tools and services that are
specific to that
blockchain yep um that's that's uh
that's that's pretty that's like pretty
darn close to how things work and how
the platform works
um you know a lot of a good analogy and
i don't want to
you know i don't want to compare
ourselves from a company perspective
obviously because we're very young as a
company we're still getting getting
started and
the space is nascent and we're helping
grow or you know our whole mission is to
help grow the
the blockchain ecosystem but a good
analogy is is um and
you know i was a startup founder in this
time but in the early 2000s
if you wanted to start a software
company you bet you were signing data
center contracts and putting servers
in a data center all over the world and
if you were scaling you were rushing to
do that all over the world
in europe in southeast asia and you know
razer asia pack
and then in 2000 don't date me on this
but 2005 or whatever
amazon starts selling its excess
capacity
to uh its servers through its ec2 and s3
offering
um and launches aws
and all of a sudden it changes the game
and provides access to
folks that want to build new products
and services to not have to
raise 20 million ducks at 20 million
bucks and and
and deploy servers all over the world
and instead can focus on the product and
experience in their core competency
and so what we're doing is actually
something uh very similar in a sense
that we're enabling companies to focus
on their core competencies so if your
core competency is an exchange
and the experience around exchanging
digital assets there's no reason you
should be focused on
deploying managing and building
computers that can actually support this
similar if you're a wallet if you're a
custodian if you're a data company
if you're trying to provide data and
analytics you shouldn't be focused on
the nuances and headache that it takes
to make sure that you know your bitcoin
nodes are syncing or ethereum archival
nodes are syncing and
uh or that you know you your your cosmos
validators are running and safe and no
one's trying to hack them
um and so we think of ourselves in a
very similar way we take
a piece of the stack uh we've
professionalized it we've created
enterprise grade infrastructure and
security around it
and we make we we sell peace of mind to
companies that want to be able to build
and
build new new products and services and
part of that is adding new assets but
it's also even covering some of the some
of the assets they were they were
previously doing before
themselves in-house and so one of the
things that i immediately think of
is okay so you've got a decentralized
network uh
and then you've got a business on the
other end of the spectrum and that
connectivity the bridge the
infrastructure
you know whatever nomenclature you want
to use uh is run by one company and so
now all of a sudden am i exposing myself
to
whether it's security or just kind of
platform risk of
uh when i sign up bison trails loves me
all of a sudden
bison charles doesn't love me and like
my business ends up kind of getting
blown up
uh or something happens to bison trails
in terms of a security breach or
something like that and then therefore
my business suffers
uh alongside that how do you guys think
about in this
world of um i won't call it
decentralization by default but i think
from an ethos perspective like
decentralization is
kind of put on this pedestal uh
rightfully so in many cases
how do you think about building the
infrastructure and is it centralized
decentralized and kind of talk me
through that
yeah absolutely so um
first things first is uh
decentralization it's funny because
you've kind of touched on this is
decentralization is a spectrum
and at least in my my personal
experience is people will draw the line
in the sand around decentralization
wherever is most convenient for them
which i think is hilarious and i think
i'm very pragmatic about that
uh you know it's kind of like you know
you could
we don't even need to get into examples
but whether it's mining pools or it's
equipment providers or it's uh you know
location
of of network there's a ton of reasons
and
and areas where these decentralized
networks are not perfect
and none of them are perfect and i think
that if you take an absolute
sort of spectrum and you say it can only
either exist perfectly decentralized in
a perfect
equilibrium or it's centralized it's a i
think it's a
it's a recipe for never innovating and
never getting anywhere
so we think of it a little bit more
pragmatically in that
yes the decentralized networks by
default and this company bison trails
was built with the ethos of
decentralization in mind from day one
so internally we think a lot of that we
think about this a lot is how do we
continue to build technology to move the
space forward build new
products and services that service these
customers like you're describing the
ones that you know
are coming in are really happy with
bison trails while at the same
time trying to move towards a better and
more decentralized network and
decentralized ecosystem
and we do a lot to support that so um
some of the things people don't
generally talk about is like absolutely
that you know we're
a company we're you know we're a
venture-backed company right
we're we are a business we're not we're
not a charity so we're you know building
the company and growing it as a business
but the idea is we want to
uh further the entire mission of the
space and
we think of that as how can we being
focused
specifically on solving this
infrastructure problem move the pieces
forward that companies that have
other focuses are not moving it forward
and so
i'm you know i would never throw any
network or any company under the bus but
this is something we actually get to see
is we can tell where these networks are
being run and it's not uncommon to see
like a huge portion of like a network
being run on like amazon
aws on the east coast and you can say
like bison trails could be
a platform risk there but the fact that
we can tell that means we can help
distribute nodes
all over the world you know in in i
don't want to quote the number of
zones and regions we have but it's in
the you know multiple dozens i think
it's something like
25 or 26 uh you know cross-section of
provider zones and regions
and we can actually reduce the risk on
the protocol itself so on the network
itself as well as
you as a customer of ours so we can
create the kind of redundancy that
you probably couldn't have done yourself
so if you were building your
exchange and you were using amazon web
services and all of a sudden there's a
horrible outage in amazon web web
services your exchange goes down
you're using the bison trails platform
we can automatically switch you over to
something like google cloud or microsoft
azure or
other cloud providers or data center
providers and
part of what we do is adding in new data
centers to create that variance and that
variety to help decentralize the network
and distribute the network
so there are ways that we're working on
that the other thing that we're doing
and this is
a little bit more ethos driven is trying
to create
technology solutions and systems that uh
provide provability around like
ownership so
who actually has control what happens if
what happens if bison trails doesn't
like us anymore
um which hopefully wouldn't happen but
uh
in in a world uh where you know you try
and create systems where you don't have
to have trust it's important to first
have trust so you can then build out the
systems and then you can kind of design
it in a way to take away the trust which
is a really good way to do this
um so we're working on technology to be
able to do that and then
uh you know the third piece for us is
really just about
you know how do we essentially
make these networks more mature how do
we make them more robust how do we
how do we build the products and
services that move
them from being you know a couple of
folks in like uh
in a dorm room on a raspberry pi into
you know
highly available highly redundant uh
network systems that
a bank like you know whatever the modern
version of a bank system
or bank company gets built can actually
trust and use
and i think that that's that's really
really important you know it's i'm not
saying banks are
definitely going to use them or they
need they need to use them i'm saying if
you're building a product and service
and you want to be able to scale
and use blockchains those blockchains
need to be reliable and right now
uh that's that's an area where we're
we're really shining is we're creating
reliability in an area where there's
been
unreliability and volatility i joke all
the time
uh some of it just literally joke around
and some of it being half serious that
jeff bezos owns majority of these
decentralized networks
for the exact point that you described
which is uh they look decentralized on
the surface but when you
actually dig into the infrastructure
itself and kind of what platforms and
where's the risk
uh it's just naturally there's three
major providers you name three of them
right google amazon
and microsoft and so there's a good shot
that uh
some portion if not a majority of a
portion of the network's gonna be
running on those services
even if you're running part of the
network and i'm running part of the
network but if we're both on amazon aws
like is it really decentralized because
you and i are
not the same personal organization but
there's this common layer
of risk right yeah and um
you know the answer to that question is
yes that's a problem but also yes that
can be much better than if that wasn't
the case
right and and that's sort of our
position here is
yeah it would be terrible if we ran
every single company every single
customer's
infrastructure on one platform that
would be catastrophic if there was an
issue
that'd be really bad which is why we
spend so much time building out what is
considered even an enterprise
like a very very modern infrastructure
platform there's a lot of companies that
are you know fortune 100 companies that
wish they could do the kinds of stuff
that bison trails is doing from an
infrastructure perspective because
we create that resilience and redundancy
so you know if
pump if you're running you know bitcoin
node and that and you need that for your
business and
it goes down and you're on bison trails
it'll be up and running and available
on google cloud or azure almost
immediately you won't even notice the
blip
and that's a very powerful thing for the
networks yeah and i think that's a key
piece which is uh when people hear a lot
of like the infrastructure stuff they
immediately think
it's everything but bitcoin right
because oh i can run the bitcoin node
myself
but you guys actually have a number of
pieces of infrastructure that can
make uh the bitcoin network more
resilient right even if it's not so much
a
decentralization thing it's you can help
the individual
uh node or the individual user at the
bitcoin level
um you know kind of benefit or or
improve their position as well exactly
and make that make that whole process
easier so it's been um
it's been super interesting and i will
say this it's a it's a constant
uh it's constantly on our company
roadmap as well and and this is this is
the advantage of
uh being a company that is designed and
built around the ethos of the crypto
space
um we want you know to put to put this
into perspective
we are a company that's entirely reliant
on the success
of the crypto and blockchain space right
like we all our eggs are in blockchain
and crypto
baskets so to speak um we want to see
these com
these uh protocols succeed and we won't
be successful if they're not successful
and if they won't be successful if
they're not properly distributed and
resilient and redundant so
our interests are very much aligned here
it's actually a very cool concept
because
we're not rewarded by being bad actors
in that respect we're actually rewarded
by being the best actors in that respect
and so
um we put a lot of time and effort and
resources and research into
building the best infrastructure
platform so that big companies can trust
and
rely on us uh you know to service you
know millions hundreds of millions of
requests on a regular basis
talk a little bit about the types of
customers you guys work with so you
mentioned earlier you know somebody who
might have a bitcoin node or something
like that but
obviously you serve all kinds of
different customers so you walk me
through some of those segments
yeah so we um it's funny
the one thing that's actually common
around all of our customer segments and
they're actually pretty different in
terms of makeup
is that they have crypto assets so uh
they
they accumulate you know we call we tend
to refer them as tokens or coins or you
know crypto assets but
they accumulate or aggregate tokens um
so these can be
funds crypto funds hedge funds you know
asset managers
you know you you name it anyone who's
sort of like investing and
we see this a lot of uh our customer
base on newer protocols where there
hasn't been a ton of token distribution
so the protocol is relatively new hasn't
been used all that much there's not like
a
robust defy ecosystem where people are
buying and trading and leveraging and
lending and all this stuff so
um tends to be a little bit more the
asset tends to be more concentrated
around like folks like early investors
and stuff we see that
um and then we have uh a larger
crypto native companies so companies
that were built specifically to solve
blockchain and crypto problems these are
the you know the exchanges and
custodians that uh that exist in the
world so
custody on a institutional basis as well
as custody on a um
individual or sort of more prosumer
basis and then exchanges
so a lot of a lot of tokens are
aggregated on exchanges people are
trading in and out of positions and
they also want to do things like stake
those assets and we provide
infrastructure to
uh large-scale exchanges to be able to
stake assets we
in march uh uh announced a collaboration
with coinbase for polka dot for the
polkadot network
um so that's that's you know a public
announcement that we did or
enabling folks that were using coinbase
custody to easily stake their polka dots
as the
the network was going live um so so
there's there's those segments and then
there's the
what we call um uh the the sort of like
crypto newcomers so there's the
these these financial institutions and
products and services that
uh existed before crypto or weren't
necessarily built specifically on
blockchains or crypto
and they enable things like trading
assets or savings accounts or finance
other financial products
and they have a desire and interest to
service their customer base that likes
crypto and so they want to be able to
have their uh customers buy or sell
bitcoin or trade bitcoin or transfer
bitcoin
um or you know do the same thing with
ethereum
they tend to be a little bit more
focused on um networks like bitcoin and
ethereum having
being that they've been around a little
bit longer and so the segments that we
have kind of
fall into you know more or less those
categories um
and then i would say that their interest
in uh the depth of interest in protocols
and the sort of range of protocols
um really depends on how long they've
been in the crypto space and we're
starting to see folks kind of like
teeter more into like
okay well now we're interested in like
tezos and cosmos and algorand and
you know and and polka dot and ethereum
two which is you know huge huge shift in
the market
uh that the ethereum network is planning
as it shifts over from proof of work
into
to proof of stake as a consensus
mechanism and participation in that
network becomes
key to being able to you know be part of
the ecosystem and that's what we do
really really well
so um that's mostly what our makeup
looks like we don't specifically talk
about who our customers are both from
for their security
for our security and you know generally
speaking um it's not
something that we do but um but that's
that's what they look like and and
you know we've been a pretty uh uh
outspoken um sort of uh
proponent for decentralized systems but
also specifically
for uh being blockchain and protocol
agnostic
so we don't you know personally as a
crypto believer i you know i'm a huge
believer in in bitcoin
and in ethereum and in you know a whole
bunch of these new networks of of
you know for them to be uh super
important for the ecosystem but as a
company we service all of them
um you know we joined we were asked to
join the libra association last year
we are we joined the libra association
and i'm a council member there i'm on
the technical steering committee
uh governing the open source project
around libra we're on
probably another dozen councils for
protocol teams so we work
really closely with blockchain protocols
and the the
the engineers and the sort of phds and
cryptography that are building these new
protocols
on one side and then we work really
closely with these companies that are
trying to
engage with and build on top of these
protocols on the other side
got it and where is bison trails going
we're like let's look towards the future
three to five years out what's kind of
the goal
and kind of any milestones along the way
that you guys really focused on hitting
so right now our biggest focus right now
being in the
short short medium term is you know
right now which is an ambiguous time
frame
uh but uh is very very sp very very
specifically unspecifically focused on
like say the next 12 to 18 months
uh is uh to make sure that these
protocols that we're helping support
that we've been helping support
things like test nets and incentivize
test nets uh
making this transition towards mainnet
which is a pretty significant milestone
for the protocols
so we view our role as a like i said
before
providing mature and robust
infrastructure to enable
lots of folks to build in this ecosystem
so for the next 12 to 18 months there's
probably about 30 protocols that we're
working really closely with that we have
been working really closely with for
you know the last two years and they're
in some transition stage of
we're pretty close to launching you
actually think a lot of these were
um some of these you know 2016-2017 icos
that you know some of the early icos
that you know raised a lot of capital
and have been working for last like
diligently for the last three years to
get these these uh these protocols built
tested and
scaled um so there's a lot of that
a lot a lot of that while we're focused
on that
we're also focused on building some
robustness around the
the products and services of what we
will what we would refer to internally
as more
mature blockchain protocols so bitcoin
being
obviously one of the oldest and or the
oldest uh
and the most mature and then you know
things like ethereum where we can
provide some tooling to folks that are
either already built on top of this
or uh would like to start adding support
for for the network and that can be
something as simple as you know
things like fast syncing nodes for
ethereum archival nodes so if you're
like doing if you're a data company and
you really want to
you know get access to ethereum data you
need to be able to connect to one of
these nodes
i don't know if you know this but
there's not a lot of people that run
ethereum archival nodes they're kind of
expensive they're clunky they're hard to
sync they take you know can take weeks
and we've built technology to do that in
very very very very short amount of time
so if you're a company that wants to do
it
you're kind of thinking like this isn't
something i want to do myself i want to
work with bison trails to do it
um i will say that if i think further
out like 5-10 years down the road
um you know we are the infrastructure
company that if you're building a
product and service you've integrated
with
in some way shape or form and that can
be at the sort of you know simplest
most raw unit uh in a blockchain which
can be at that node level
or it can be a product and service
that's a little bit higher up the stack
and that can be things like indexing or
data retrieval or uh or apis to
to produce content for blockchain or
to consume content from a blockchain got
it and what do you think the biggest
obstacles are for for you to kind of
accomplish some of that
um i think you know uh this is where it
kind of gets into beliefs
and beliefs around uh the blockchain
space um i think that
uh the the world that we're in today
is has been um you know the fact that we
are all as
as humans have become a little bit more
remote um become a little bit more
distant
uh is actually uh almost cognitively
more aligned with blockchain systems
and and crypto networks which i'm
finding very very fascinating
and i think that the uh i believe that
one of the
the knock-on effects of this is this um
creativity that's going to spark
from you know from the this the world
that we're in today
that will uh create a bloom of
entrepreneurship uh around blockchains
and
and uh transfer value networks and this
actually happened
in early internet days as well like post
internet crash there was like a pretty
it was pretty bad like the world the
quote-unquote world was in like not a
great
great spot in a sense not you know there
wasn't a pandemic around but
um you know economically speaking the
the world was not a great spot and a lot
of times
uh the best infrastructure companies are
built in these sort of economic
downturns
because that's when it's like time to
sort of lay the groundwork
and then you see this explosion of
entrepreneurship on top of it and so
um you know barriers to enter sorry
barriers to success for us
not to entry but various success for us
is going to be uh
making sure that we do a good job
helping these protocols scale
and make them more accessible and
democratize access to
to them um the the crypto and blockchain
sys
ecosystem needs to continue to grow that
is that is like
full stop what's the most important
thing for us and our company is tasked
with helping that
and we're doing it from a ease of use
and ease of access perspective
and so if we can't achieve that goal
then that that would be a challenge
you know fundamentally a challenge for
bison trails but if we can continue to
see
if some of these protocols grow and
launch and new products and services
um happen then we're we're in a great
spot and
you know the truth is i've never worked
in an industry that had the pace of
innovation that the crypto industry has
i mean i know
two years ago dfi was just like a word
you would hear at a meetup once in a
while
you know it was not a thing now you know
we're talking about like
you know the grand scheme of things
still small ecosystem but from a crypto
perspective and growth perspective like
you know multi-billion dollar
uh ecosystem like that that is
incredible and so we will continue to
see
innovation happen at that pace and it'll
be in finance it'll be
centralized sorry it'll be in
decentralized finance it'll be in things
like payments and marketplaces and
data transfer and you know you're gonna
start to see all these verticals
uh and that's where i'm excited for the
future of bison trails and that we're
gonna help support all these verticals
as they continue to grow
before we get into the rapid fire
questions to end it uh
where can we go find out uh more about
bison trails on the internet and also
find you
yeah so bison trails you can uh email us
hi at bisontrails.com or visit us on the
web at bisontrails.com you can learn
about the protocols we support we also
produce a ton of content on our blog
explaining the really tough nuances of
how these different protocols work we do
a ton of research and produce it in a
way that makes it consumable and easy
for people to understand so you can
check that out
uh at bicentral.com we're also on
twitter
at bisontrails we tweet all the stuff
out too if you're on twitter and you
wanna
wanna find us and then me personally i'm
at joella luz on twitter
that's the place to get me awesome
uh first rapid fire question what is the
most important book
that you've ever read
uh oh man i feel like i have recency
bias here
uh i loved the diamond edge by neil
stephenson
um why it uh it reminded me
that uh it reminded me of this idea that
um you can build the future the
technology future and you could
end up on either the good side or the
bad side of it and that you should
always remember to stay on the good side
of it
okay that's fair i haven't read it so
i'm gonna have to read that one that
sounds like something i would enjoy
it's a good book and it actually has a
lot a lot to do with crypto and
blockchains in the sense that like
you you could almost envision a future
dystopian world
um where like the a lot of the
fundamentals around crypto have come
true which is cool
aliens believer or non-believer
um believer that
humans shouldn't be so self-centered
that we think we can be the only life
forms in the universe and that it's too
big for it not to be possible so
a believer in like the sort of for
science perspective
not because i've seen them
i well actually i can't say i i've had i
think two or three people come on and
say they've seen ufos no one said claim
to see an alien but ufos for sure
uh they don't exist
i guess it's like my my perspective i'm
with you
it's always this weird thing but i also
i joke with you all the time like
we always think of space but i've seen
some videos of stuff in the ocean
and i'm like hey man i didn't learn
about that in school like i don't know
what that is but that does not look like
anything i've ever heard of before
the ocean if the ocean is telling enough
about what could be in space
it's like too dangerous absolutely uh to
finish
up you get to ask me one question what
is the one question you have for me
uh if
let's see if
is there a world where blockchains and
crypto succeed but bitcoin does not
exist
yes but i'm gonna caveat it with
bitcoin to me is the only shot we have
at separation of state and money
and so you could see that fail
but other types of decentralized
networks whatever like that wins
it's just uh two very separate problems
right so like i always say bitcoin and
crypto because
crypto to me is like all the
non-currency
type applications where i think people
are still kind of like sifting through
the various opportunities and saying
like what are the opportunities they're
worth going after
how much is that avail like how much
market cap
is available if you're the successful
winner there uh who are the right teams
like there's a lot of
unknowns and that's where fortunes will
get kind of made or lost on
uh with bitcoin i think i think we're at
the point now where it's like at least
in my opinion like
it's either bitcoin or nothing right in
terms of separating state and money
um and so while yes it uses some of the
same underlying technology
yes it has a lot of the same ethos like
it's a very very different type of
problem
um because a lot of the crypto problems
are both technical and like user
experience and all that kind of stuff
yeah the money problem is more like
belief system
and uh game theory then let's say like
uh
you know traditional crypto network um
and so
it's by separating them it makes it i
think a little bit more clearer like you
can get a world where
bitcoin is the only successful thing and
all the other crypto stuff fails or vice
versa like
bitcoin could not separate state money
and then you could get other things that
uh end up using kind of triple entry
accounting blockchain etcetera that are
valuable that's awesome it's good it's
good
it's good oh man there's like i have
like seven follow-ups but we're good
trust me and every bitcoin maximus in
the world's probably gonna like
come find me now but hey they know i
listen i'm on board i'm on board more
than probably anybody else
no but this is uh this is great man uh
we will send people bisontrails.co
um and uh just generally think what you
guys are doing super important and
anytime you can get people to uh to kind
of democratize access
access uh to something it ends up
usually leading to pretty good things so
just keep at it i appreciate it
and uh just before uh before we jump i
just wanted to say thanks so much for
having me and
um like i said you chan and uh love the
work that you're doing and keep it up
and you know really i think your fans
appreciate you know folks watching and
listening
i really appreciate the work you do so
thanks thanks again for having me here
i'm having fun you're having fun let's
just keep going yeah
love it